- [Newscaster] The Turkish
army opened up with tank
and artillery fire,
on Greek Cypriot positions
near the Nicosia airport.
- I'm on an island in the Mediterranean,
and I'm at an airport, on the
runway right now actually.
This airport is completely empty.
It's totally still, there's no one here.
It's Eerie.
It's empty. It's falling apart.
(background chatter)
The reason this airport is a ghost town
is because we are literally
inside of a border.
(suspenseful music)
This is Cypress.
It is an island. That's just under Turkey,
just to the left of Lebanon and Israel.
So yeah, I'm locked inside
of a border right now,
which I'll explain what I
mean by that in a little bit.
But the shorter answer, is
that this is a gray zone,
it is in no man's land. And in fact,
challenges what we even
mean by the word country.
This airport used to be a thriving hub
of international travel,
people everywhere.
And then that changed. It
changed because of an invasion.
- [Newscaster] The Turkish
air attacks came sporadically,
but swiftly, the main targets
were Greek Cypriot police,
the national guard building,
and above all, the airport,
where there was some heavy fighting today.
(dramatic music)
The Greek Cypriots,
sizeably outnumbered by the Turks,
were able to put up a little resistance.
- And not that long ago,
we're talking like the 1970s.
It was that conflict
that locked this place
into a no man's land,
into a conflict that still
continues to this day.
(upbeat music)
This airport is not the story here.
This is just one piece of a huge puzzle.
It's a puzzle and a situation
that I've been thinking about
for years, the better part of a decade.
I've been staring at this
place, thinking about it,
looking at it.
And I'm finally here.
I'm finally here to look at it
in the face to understand it,
to talk to the people,
to look at its story and
to try to piece together
an explanation of how
this island was divided,
not between two countries,
but divided into four.
- [Newscaster] The island where Aphrodite,
the Greek goddess of love
was born out of sea spray.
Cyprus is Britain's
base in the Middle East
and the Middle East is
under constant pressure.
In addition to clashes with
rebelling Greek Cypriots,
the British are faced
with keeping the peace
between the Turkish, Greek protections.
Sizably outnumbered by the Turks,
we're able to put up little resistance.
The Greeks had no hope for victory.
Hate and fear now rules Cyprus.
- I came to this island
because I wanted to understand
something I've been
thinking about for years.
I studied it back in grad school,
but never really understood it.
So after years of reading
about this conflict
and looking at it on a map, I came,
I met up with some friends
who were also traveling
in this region and who
also wanted to learn,
to expand their perspectives
on this poorly understood conflict.
(campfire crackling)
- So you say the island
is divided into four,
but what are the four parts?
- To understand that,
you have to look at the maps,
(drums beating)
even though the country of
Cyprus is a member of the EU
and their flag literally
has an island on it.
It has the entire island on it,
the Republic of Cyprus actually
looks like this. It only takes
up 60% of the actual island,
it's made up of mostly
people who identify as Greek.
So this is it.
This is the country of Cyprus,
only controls this portion of the island.
It's just 60% of the island.
- Wait.
- Okay? So that's not the whole island.
What is the remaining portion?
- The remaining 40% is complicated.
First off, you have a small fraction
of this island that is
controlled by, wait for it,
the British, the British,
yes, you guessed it.
- I saw that coming.
- Yes, didn't we all, the British,
they mainly use it for military purposes.
And then you have this strip right here,
that is owned by no country.
This is controlled by the United Nations.
It's a buffer zone,
a ceasefire line set up in
the sixties and seventies
to stop the fighting.
Now the elephant in the room here,
which is the rest of this map,
all of this up here is
controlled by the self-declared
Turkish Republic of Northern Cyprus.
According to the UN and
almost every other country.
This space is not a country,
the self-declared
country, that is occupying
half of this island almost.
But if you go to this place,
it feels like a country.
It has like a government that builds roads
and infrastructure and has
political parties and elections.
So it's.
- So it is a country?
- Kind of, it's kind of a country.
- How can you be kind of a country?
This land up here is occupied
because there was an invasion
in the seventies.
And at that time, Greeks
and Turks had to separate.
They left their homes, completely empty.
Thinking, maybe they would
come back, but they never did.
- [Newscaster] As the Turks advanced,
the number of Greek Cypriot refugees,
pouring into the Dhekelia
base, is growing rapidly.
- There's this city, in what
is now the occupied north,
that used to be this
beautiful resort town.
When the invasion
happened, the people fled.
There was a bombing on
this town and they all fled
and they thought, okay,
once the bombings over,
we'll come back.
And they never did.
It's been 47 years and
they have not gone back.
They left their homes,
they left food in their refrigerators.
They left their pictures, their jewelry,
just in their homes.
I met a guy who left that day.
He was 33. He took his two
children and they drove.
And after months of talking
to the Turkish military,
we got permission to go back
with him to visit his old home
and to talk about that experience.
(ethereal music)
- Wait, how could this city possibly go
from idyllic resort, to
the ghost town basically?
- That's that is the question
I've been thinking about
for a lot of years now.
And to understand it,
it really helps to go back.
(snare drums beating)
The first thing to know, and the,
the context of this island
is that everyone wanted it.
Always.
This place is located so
perfectly in the Mediterranean
at the crossroads of
Europe and the Middle East
and Northern Africa,
that it is so perfectly
strategically located.
Everyone wanted it.
It was the Persians and
Alexander the Great.
And then of course,
the Romans show ups with
their Jesus religion
and do that thing.
You get the point, like Cyprus
was just a strategic pond
being conquered and ruled
by one empire after another
for literally thousands of years.
And that gets us up to 500 years ago,
which is closer to the
root of today's conflict.
When the empire from Turkey,
the Ottoman empire came over,
they threw out the current
empire, which has the Venetian,
and they came in and they're
like the Ottoman empire,
now rules Cyprus.
- So I don't mean to interrupt
because this is all fascinating,
but I have always had the
question of whether Turkey
is named after the bird, or
if it's the other way around.
And this is just something
that's bugging me forever.
And I figured I'd ask you.
- I mean, we,
we were talking about like
the concrete of this land,
but we can talk about
turkeys for a little bit.
So the answer to that is, turkey the bird,
is definitely named
after Turkey, the empire.
Okay.
The way that it works is that
Turkic people used to bring
this bird into Europe and
sell it and they would buy it
and they would call it a Turkey fowl.
Oh, there's like this Turkey fowl.
It's this bird coming from Turkey,
when Europeans arrived to North America
and they saw what we call turkeys today.
They're like, oh,
that looks just like the Turkey fowl
from like back in Europe,
the Turks used to bring over.
- Oh Wow
- Let's call it a Turkey.
Even though it's a totally
different animal than the,
than the thing that
Turks are bringing over.
And that's how we got turkeys.
So the thing you eat for
Thanksgiving or whatever is like,
is like named after Turkey.
- So not,
not that dumb of a question.
- Do you feel satisfied
with your Turkey answer?
Cause we can move on about
the point of the video,
which is about like how the
island was divided into four.
Or do you want to keep
talking about Turkey?
Because I can tell you
about turkeys like all day.
- No, I think it's okay. Yeah.
- You feel satisfied?
- [Johnny's friends]
Thanks for taking the time.
- Okay. So we're at the point
where the Ottoman empire,
the Turkey empire owns Cyprus. Okay?
And this is where Turkic
people arrive to this island
and they find mostly Greek
people, Greek Christians,
Turkic Muslims, different cultures.
And yet over the years,
they made a harmonious society
together where they lived
next to each other, in the same
villages and towns in peace.
Let's get to modern day because
it's like the late 1800's,
Ottoman empire is crumbling,
like super crumbling.
And who is the new kid on the
block that is not crumbling,
but is rising? The British.
- So it's not that surprising to me,
that the next part of
the story is the British,
coming into a part of this,
but why would they want,
this specific island?
- There was particularly this
one little strip of water
that made all the difference.
The Suez canal was this
new man-made canal that cut
the time from Britain
to India, like in half,
like it was so much
easier to get to India.
One of their major colonies
and Britain was like,
we need to control that. And oh,
Cyprus is right there
next to the Suez canal.
Like it's a perfect
Lily pad for us to have.
- [Newscaster] The great
importance of Cypress
can be seen from the map,
important little island
in the Mediterranean.
It has become a strategic
center in the Middle East zone
of this world war.
- So this is the big
turning point in the story.
The British owned Cyprus
is one of their colonies
and they're doing what the
British do well, which is like,
they're making maps,
they're doing demographics.
And they're like, oh,
you are Turkish Muslims.
And you are Greek Christians.
And they're like separating
people by like identity,
just sort of on paper.
The people who've been living
here for thousands of years
and being conquered by every empire,
you can imagine, finally start
to get fed up with all this.
- [Newscaster] One British
army truck is bombed,
killing two soldiers and wounding 12.
- By the 1950s Cypriots were done
with British rule.
And they had risen up in violent attacks
against the British.
The British realized it was
time to go home and it looked
like Cypriots for the
first time would actually
be able to govern themselves
instead of being tossed
around by outside powers.
But the Greek Cypriots
didn't want independence.
They actually wanted to join Greece.
This was a political
movement called a Enosis.
Meanwhile,
the Turkish Cypriots didn't
want to be a part of Greece.
They didn't want to become
even more of a minority.
They instead wanted to divide the island
into two new independent countries,
one for Greek Cypriots and
one for Turkish Cypriots.
This is what a power
vacuum will do to people.
When the fate of who's
going to be in control
is up for grabs,
people latch onto their groups
and inflate their identities
to divide themselves, from the other side.
These were no longer just
Cypriots like they had been
for centuries.
Now they had to choose a team,
team Turkey or team Greece.
And so this is the climax.
This is actually where the
conflict becomes a big deal.
- [Newscaster] 1955 saw Sir
John Harding as governor
and commander in-chief,
attempting to reconcile a
Greek and Turkish viewpoints,
all British proposals,
however were rejected and
a long period of riots
and outrages followed.
- The British realized
that these divisions
between Turks and Greeks on the island,
that they had helped create.
We're now getting out of control.
So they pulled a page out
of their old playbook.
- [Newscaster] And a new
British plan described
as an adventure in partnership
- The plan was a classic one,
to gather in London for a few days,
with a few leaders and outside powers
and decide for the Cypriots,
how their country was going to be run.
And that's what they did.
They all sat in the room and
they wrote a constitution
for Cyprus and Greece and Turkey
were like both in the room.
And they were like,
we know that you sort of want
to like join Greece maybe,
or maybe you want to
have your own country.
You're going to get neither of those.
You're going to be an independent country.
And we're going to create this
really clever constitution
where the president has to be Greek,
but the vice-president has to be Turkish.
And there has to be like a certain number
of Greeks and Turks.
And like they created this
like really clever constitution
that was going to make
everyone happy in theory.
And then they're like, you're
going to be independent.
But we,
the British get to stay here
with our bases and Greece
and Turkey get to kind
of have power still.
Like if something goes awry,
like they can swoop in.
If they really need to, that
was like a caveat to this,
this agreement that they made in London.
And in 1960, it happened.
- [Newscaster] Midnight in Nicosia.
And Sir Hugh Foot entering parliament
is followed by Archbishop Makarios,
who is to take over as first president
of Cyprus.
So representatives of the
two Cypriot communities
and of Greece, Turkey, and Britain,
begin the signing ceremony,
there are many documents to be signed.
- Do any of us think
that the British crafting
a constitution,
that's cleverly put together
to make everyone get along?
It's really going to work. No.
Right.
- That sounds extremely flimsy.
- It's very flimsy.
- Telling other people,
how they should structure
their country is.
- Never really works. And it's like,
we've seen that quite
a few times. It's like,
is anyone going to learn that,
unsurprisingly, the whole,
we wrote you a constitution
that says you should
all get along thing,
didn't work out and tensions
between Greeks and Turks
started to heat up.
- [Newscaster] For some time,
hatred between the Greek
and Turkish elements
have been building up,
under such conditions,
it takes more than a treaty
to preserve the peace.
- I have this amazing map.
I mean, actually you should see this.
Remember that I mentioned
that like Greeks and Turks
sort of live together,
as this constitution,
isn't working out violence against Turks
who were always the minority,
led them to leave their home.
And they start to gather into
these little enclaves around
the country.
- [Newscaster] The Turkish
Cypriots were declaring
that it would be impossible, ever again,
to live in harmony with
their Greek compatriots.
- And so the map went
from looking like this,
to looking like this.
- [Newscaster] The
strategic island continues
to be the scene of daily
violence and bloodshed.
- Over in Greece,
the new military government
saw this happening and thought
that this would be a moment
to swoop in and take over
the government of Cyprus
and try to realize this dream of Cyprus
being united with Greece.
Then that's when Turkey's like, Greece,
you violated the agreement.
We weren't supposed to
swoop in on the island.
And unless there was
something really wrong.
And so we're going to swoop
in because we technically
on paper say that we can come
in and restore the peace.
Well, they did a lot more
than restore the peace.
(suspenseful music)
Turkey swoops in and starts
taking over the north
in a full blown invasion with bombs
and tanks and military, like troops,
like hitting the like beaches with guns,
like a full-blown invasion.
And they start just taking
over the north of the island
and the people start fleeing,
the Greeks who realized that Turkey
is actually invading and
Turkey feels justified
because they feel like
Greece did it first.
And so they just keep going.
- [Newscaster] From the battle going high
over the capital city.
The Greek Cypriots sizably
outnumbered by the Turks
were able to put up little resistance.
- I've been glued to these
early reports of the invasion
of the island of Cyprus by Turkey.
There's this one journalist
from the UK named Jonathan Dimbleby,
who was like one of the
first on the ground,
when all of this was happening.
And he captures the feelings
of the people who had to flee
their homes to their side of the line.
- We didn't take anything with us.
- In these reports,
you start to hear two
totally different narratives.
And these will go on to be
the roots of the modern day
conflict on the island of Cyprus.
The first narrative is
the Greek narrative,
from their perspective,
this is an invasion to their country,
a theft of their property.
Turkey was invading
their sovereign territory
and forcing them to leave land.
That was rightfully theirs.
- [Newscaster] It is unlikely,
- That the Turks will allow them back
and there is no promise that
they will be compensated
for their confiscated homes
and businesses.
It is as if the Greek Cypriot
world has come to an end.
- We prepared to be dead.
Than to live under the Turkish authority.
(women sobbing)
- But for Turkish Cypriots,
this was not an invasion.
This was salvation, Turkish Cypriots
had suffered immense
violence and brutality
as minorities on the island,
at the hand of their Greek compatriots.
And now Turkey was
swooping in to save them,
to protect them.
That's why Turkish Cypriots
call this, the peace operation.
- When I, saw the Turks,
I forget my unhappiness,
I was very happy because
my, my life was saved.
My children's life was safe.
And my, my people, I mean,
the Turks was all safe.
I'm very happy. Of course.
- People, the Turkish
population feel more safe,
secure because the Turkish
army is there to protect them.
- After three days of an
unstoppable offensive,
the Turkish army,
seems to have grabbed just
about all the land that
it wants on Cypress,
at least in the Northern
and Northeastern parts
of the island.
- And then the Turks in the
north declared a new country.
They were like,
we are now the Turkish
Republic of Northern Cyprus,
a new country. It's effectively
just Turkey by another name
To stop the fighting,
the UN carved out these twin
lines that cut right through
the capital of Nicosia,
they stretch across the whole island,
a buffer zone to stop the violence.
And this establishes
the lines we know today,
with the Republic of Cyprus
controlling all of this,
the self-declared Turkish
Republic of Northern Cyprus,
up here, then of course,
the British with the land that
they held onto when Cyprus
became independent and
then this, UN buffer zone,
which locks within its
boundaries, the airport,
along with people's homes,
businesses, and farms.
This is an island divided into four.
- [Newscaster] In one way
only, are Greek and Turk alike.
They both now belong to
a nation of refugees.
- One of the reasons I came
here was because I wanted to see
what this looks like after
years of looking at it on a map,
what does it feel like for the
people to pick up and leave
and flee to their side
of this new boundary,
abandoning their lives and communities.
We're about to go into Northern
Cyprus for the first time.
Here we go.
As you drive through the occupied north,
you see a lot of churches like this.
(piano music)
I'm in a village where
Greek Cypriots used to live,
but in 1974, they fled south,
leaving this village empty.
The Turkish Cypriots,
who were in the south,
fled north and arrived to this
village to find empty homes
and this Christian church.
(piano music)
And they converted it into a mosque
so that they could continue
their religious practices.
But eventually they built a
new mosque, right next door.
And they left this
church totally abandoned,
where it lays today, falling apart.
(piano music)
Both sides suffered immense losses.
And now empty buildings are
the most visceral solid symbol
of that loss.
These abandoned churches
are peppered all throughout
the occupied north,
(piano music)
(campfire crackling)
But perhaps the most haunting
symbol of this switching
of sides happened here, in that
thriving Greek tourist town
called Famagusta.
- [Newscaster] Famagusta
was the tourist resorts
of the island. The major port,
much of the wealth of Greek
Cyprus was based here.
Last weekend, the Greeks fled in panic
before the Turkish tanks.
They have abandoned all that they have
and they won't return.
Now, the town is deserted.
(ethereal music)
- We're about to go in.
I've been thinking about this place for,
the better part of a decade.
And we're about to go in.
The reason I spent months
trying to get access to film
in this ghost town.
Wasn't just to capture it,
but rather to understand the human tragedy
that happened here. So I asked
this man to come with me.
His name is Mr. Takis,
he's a Greek Cypriot who
was my age back in 1974.
He lived here in
Famagusta. He owned hotels.
He was in the tourism industry,
but when Turkey invaded,
he did what everyone
else did in this town.
He left with his family.
And today he's returning
for the first time ever.
- This is not easy to bear.
It brings out anger. It
brings out confusion.
It brings out disappointment.
My wife refused to come.
I came with my daughters
today. I came with them, but
they tell me "you don't talk."
I lost my, I cannot connect.
- Can you paint a picture to
me on what Famagusta was like?
- The economy was so strong here.
Not only economically, Johnny,
but culturally, educationally.
It was a wonderful period.
- I asked Mr. Takis,
if you would be comfortable
showing me his old home.
So we started walking through what used
to be his entire world,
the cafe he used to come to
often, his brother's old house,
where he went to school.
- I spent some of my best years yet.
- Wow.
The school is now boarded
up and covered with Turkish
and TRNC flags.
- To see this in this situation
makes me very, very sad.
- As we walked through this ghost town,
I kept trying to get Mr. Takis
to go back to the Famagusta
of before the invasion
and to point out the places
that he had good memories from.
What do you remember about
that time. But after a while,
he finally just stopped me.
- Johnny, I told you before,
I cannot connect. I cannot.
You are asking about my memories.
- Yeah.
- They don't bring out,
the full memories I want to describe
because, there is a reservation,
this is not the town I lived.
This is not the town that I was proud of.
- Yeah.
- This is not the town
that has tremendous history
and success.
It is unbelievable.
- On that day that everyone had to flee,
you thought you'd be coming back.
- Yes, for sure.
Everybody who left, thought
they were going away
for two, three days.
They didn't take anything
more than clothes and food.
- We walked through this
city deep in conversation.
And then Mr. Takis's
friend, who was with us,
signaled that we were
getting close to the house.
The one he hadn't seen since
he fled all those years ago,
Mr. Takis didn't pick up that
we were getting so close.
And when he looked up,
he realized we were here.
Tell me about this building?
- What should I say?
- I could tell he felt caught off guard.
And I began to regret having
set this whole thing up.
- Well, you didn't prepare me.
- [Johnny] I was subjecting this man
to a traumatic reopening
of his old wounds.
All so I could make my
video about the conflict.
It started to not feel right,
but he assured me that we could keep going
and that he wanted to do this.
- No, I want to go on the other side.
Let's go from the beach.
- He didn't want me to see his home
from this angle, from
this bombed out street.
Instead he wanted to see
it from the other side,
from the beach,
the part of this town that
still has some semblance
of its former glory.
- Not from here. From the other side.
I didn't realize, we
had reached the house.
- Yeah, It looks like there's
an entrance over here, maybe.
- Now you will get, an idea
of why it was so popular.
I think seeing.
- [Johnny] Yeah, I haven't
seen the beach yet.
- This is the famous
sandy beach of Famagusta.
- As we walked towards his
house. Now from the beach side,
it was clear that Mr.
Takis still felt deep pride
for this place, this beach, this city.
- In certain areas, there
is even turquoise water.
- It's stunning. It's beautiful.
And though his city and his
property and his stories are now
a ghost town, occupied
by an invading power.
When you're on this beach,
you don't feel it as much.
- Beaches like this, there
are not many in the world.
- No there really aren't.
- Especially with turquoise water.
(ethereal music)
- And then after a moment
walking along this beach,
we finally approached his home.
This is the first time you're seeing this.
- The first time I have
seen it after 47 years.
It hurts me, I cannot
connect in the sense that,
what I see doesn't bring
out all those nice memories
and the good times that you had.
You have to close your eyes
and then it all comes back.
- [Newscaster] Famagusta
was the tourist resort
of the island.
All this belonged to the Greeks.
Famagusta this morning, was a ghost town.
It is unlikely that the
Turks will allow them back.
- We didn't prepare.
My wife still refuses to come
because it's painful.
I come here to do what?
Like now we see it and
I cannot go into it.
What is the purpose?
I'm not a tourist. It's
my home. It's my town.
And I come here and you can't
go here, you can't go there.
You can see your house from distance.
It's a torture, It's a torture.
I know it's difficult for everybody
to get into somebody else's shoes,
but I'm sure you appreciate
that it hurts a lot.
It hurts a lot, hurts a lot.
It's not right.
- I watched Mr. Takis take
a photo with his daughters,
who he had brought to see the
house they almost grew up in,
they stood in front of the
Turkish military border
that bars them from actually going inside.
And in that moment, I felt a
profound sadness for it all.
Unlike anything that I'd felt in the years
of studying this conflict.
(campfire crackling)
Those conversations are so
important because like this isn't
just a international relations issue.
This is like a human issue.
It's like people and their identity
and their homes being lost because
of great power conflicts. To me,
it's much more important
to have those types
of conversations then
just to be zoomed out,
looking at a map.
Both Greek and Turkish Cypriots
suffered immense violence
and loss of their homes and communities
in 1974 and the years leading up to it.
And throughout this series,
I want to shed light,
not just on this history,
but what it feels like to
live in this place today.
A country divided into
four, full of buffer zones
and barriers and division.
At the end of the day,
this is a division, that was
constructed by outside powers,
which is the story of Cyprus.
The story of a strategically
placed island that everyone
wanted and was ripped apart,
purely because of where it was located.
(piano music)
Okay, well, you made it through
episode one of Uncharted,
this pilot series of something that I want
to do a lot more of. There
are three more episodes.
So this is just the beginning.
This is a new form of
journalism that I am pushing.
And I'm really grateful to
the sponsor who supported it,
which is Cometeer.
Cometeer is kind of blowing my mind.
They're a completely
different version of coffee
than anything I've ever experienced.
The way it works is that Cometeer,
works with some of the
best artisanal roasteries
around the world.
And they make beautiful, wonderful coffee.
They brew it themselves,
but then they immediately flash freeze it.
Like they freeze it in these
insanely low temperatures
to like seal in the freshness
and the aromas and the flavors
of this roasted coffee.
And then they put it in
these little metal capsules
and send them to your house, frozen.
They show up, you pull
them out of these capsules.
You put them into a cup with hot water
and you have delicious coffee,
that is like the coffee that was brewed.
I mean, it's, it's brilliant.
And it tastes really good.
Listen, I'm a big coffee guy.
And I like to think
that I have like the art
of the pourover down, with like my scale
and like my timer and all this stuff.
Honestly, it takes a long time,
which is fine on a weekend.
But like during the week,
like I sort of want a
more convenient option.
I could pay for a coffee shop to make it
and have it delivered to my house,
which costs me a lot of
money or I could pay way less
and have a really good cup
of coffee that is reliable
and sustainably packaged.
And all of this stuff through Cometeer.
Cometeer is kind of a new thing.
They're not fully open to the public yet.
There's some waitlist.
If you want to bypass that waitlist,
there's a link in my description,
it is cometeer.com/johnnyharris,
that allows you
to bypass the waitlist and get
50% off your first purchase,
which makes this like $1 per cup,
which is insanely cheap for the quality
of coffee you're getting.
So if this is interesting to you,
go to the link in my description,
clicking that link helps
support this channel,
but it also gives you that 50% off
and allows you to bypass the waitlist.
I feel really excited
that I discovered this
and we'll be using it for
the foreseeable future.
So thank you Cometeer
for sponsoring this video
and thank you all for being here.
There are three more
episodes of Uncharted coming
to you in the next few weeks.
So keep an eye out for
those. See you later.
(trumpet music)